moving forward that was very much like a
rock and a hard place when we were
looking at 2020. it's getting bad now
and so i think desantis is great he's
like trump in a lot of ways but he's not
a bombast you know what i mean so of
course the media will go after him and
try to vilify him but he's more tactful
he's half the age of trump he doesn't
appear to be a narcissist either which i
respect
i don't agree with a lot of his
positions and so i'm not saying i would
vote for the guy i'm just saying i
probably would not support trump
considering we've learned our lessons
and we have an opportunity for you know
someone else that being said i've never
been a big fan of the two-party system
like i said i didn't vote in 2012 or
2016. and 2020 was only because
it was just a crazy time to be
completely honest and now i'm like it
may get crazy or probably will we're in
the low year where there's no elections
so things are calm views and ratings are
a little low everyone's kind of chilling
out midterms next year it's going to be
what do you think do you think do you
think the gop have a chance to
definitely take the house i think they
will take it you think so there's a long
way to go a lot of people are running
it's really fascinating to like see all
of these
uh what's the new term america first
america first people running
i kind of i'm interested to see what uh
what they have to say for themselves
this is what i'm saying i think people
have learned a lot of lessons and that
means that come 2024 i don't think trump
will be as necessary as people think he
was last year or even right now
i think we're already seeing early signs
that you've got a desantis perhaps again
not a i'm not a i'm not a conservative i
don't completely agree i'd i'd be more
inclined to vote libertarian and that's
only because of dave smith
otherwise
i don't even know who i'd vote for yeah
i need some some like technology talk
from dave otherwise i can't get on with
like the whole break it down concept
like i've been listening to him lately a
little bit but he's been like yeah we
need to undo this and undo that and like
okay
give me what are we going to do what's
next and i think here's the difference
like a technology board or something i'm
down dave let's do this and absolutely
and that's
i think the what's inspiring about
dave is that he's a guy you can talk to
he's not out of reach and out of touch
and more interested in
you know the consultants what they're
going to say what size shoe or color tie
or anything like that that's one of the
problems we have two-party system is
it's just machine regimented and trump
kind of broke that in a lot of ways but
back to what you were saying about all
these midterm people running people are
learning the lessons a lot of america
first types of a lot of um populist
types right are now running and there's
a huge opportunity i think what we saw
in 2020 the over performance in the mid
i'm sorry in congress of the republicans
it's going to be
it's going to be even crazier because
look
this is what happened with trump in
2016.
they they they take everything trump's
voters came out for trump and the
republicans but in 2018 trump's voters
did not turn out this is this is true i
went through the data 2018. in 2018
trump's voters were
less okay and so that for like the
midterms yes right so be so what
happened was in 2016 when trump's voters
came out they voted down ticket
republican
but because those people did not come
out in 2018 to a certain degree was lost
republicans ended up losing a lot of
seats because that's when we got like
aoc and all those guys that's right and
i think 31 seats flipped from a
republican to democrat because without
trump's name on the ticket the trump
voters so many trump voters were
first-time voters or independent voters
now we're moving into 2022 i think a lot
of people have learned lessons
and joe biden was the the will take
whatever we can get to stop trump right
now they've lost that
they have lost to the name trump as well
so how many regular people are going to
come out in 2022 all dancing and
cheering saying and the orange
back the party that's been
doing by that point will have been done
doing such a poor job of handling this
uh
whole covet situation and that's
interesting too when you watch the poll
numbers dropping the worse kova gets and
the less
uh control over it the white house can
maintain
the more abundance ratings are going to
tank people are going to want him gone
he staked his whole presidency on
solving several crises and that's why
you see you know you saw so much with
covet but that's why they're trying to
pivot so hard to climb it they really
want to get to climate so that they can
tackle the next crisis and be heroes
again when you look at the disdain
people had for trump and they did i know
a lot of people don't want to believe it
but trump did increase his his voter
base by a large number he had more votes
than any sitting president in history
but biden got more and i hear from
people who like they don't believe it
and i'm like dude but i told you
yeah i told this to steve bannon i know
people who are as dumb as a box of rocks
who have no business in politics and
couldn't tell you
even the name of the parties right who
are posting videos going and voting by
mail or who are posting the videos of
getting their bouts and voting with them
and i'm like listen
i believe when they say like why why do
people vote biden but not down ballot
i'm like because they're not political
people they saw the celebrity on tv the
entertainment was shut down for a year
nobody could go to the movies and they
were being the people were screaming in
their face trump is evil and they're
like ah and so they just write biden
send it in
and the republicans were able to take a
bunch of seats in in in congress
now imagine what's gonna happen without
the threat of trump and even the down
ballot votes they did get it's like
i think republicans are going to do
fairly well they only need to win what
like 11 seats
there's a long time between now and then
so i'm not going to make any predictions
i don't know i just think based on
current uh trajectory that may be a a
fair assessment but don't you think that
there's also a chance that the uh the
democrats are going to completely
overhaul the voting system yes i mean if
you look in california gavin newsom has
his recall election coming up but
california just made it possible i'm
pretty sure that you can print your
at your ballots yeah i saw that and then
there's a lot of people can come and
collect it for you and come and advise
you on that
and they've done such an incredible job
the democrats of vilifying the um
different voting integrity laws that
have sprung up in what like something
like
22
states 28 states yeah a lot like a whole
bunch of states and if you actually you
know they say they're jim crow and
they're exclusionary and discriminatory
and all this stuff and if you actually
look at those laws if you take the time
to read the laws
they don't say what the white house says
they say
it's not about that and if you read hr1
like i did a deep dive into hr1 it's 800
something pages
of rules about voting that have
absolutely nothing to do with anything
other than preventing states from making
their own laws so i looked up the um
it's called the remote access remote
accessible vote by mail is this the
california thing yes you can print your
selection sign the envelope and then
return the printed and signed selections
either by mail or dropping it off in a
voting location
uh the selections cannot be returned
electronically so the answer is yes
you can request to vote at home print
out your your
says you download the application mark
your selections print their selections
sign the envelope using the envelope
provided with the vote by mail ballot or
the voter's own envelope
cool that is not sketchy at all
this is from
sos.ca.gov
return the printed and signed selections
either by mail or by dropping off at a
voting location
uh
well there you go what you can now just
uh print out your vote this is you know
ian this is the opposite of blockchain
yeah
this is where my nihilism is coming from
it is blatantly obvious that if you have
a proprietary voting machine counting
votes it's not secure and that we have
an opportunity to attempt to secure it
with a third blockchain like you still
do what we're doing plus a blockchain
layer
but literally zero security on the
system so that's obvious prints out your
ballot how how has that not been adopted
that that to me either shows that people
are are very stupid in general and we're
just destined for extinction or there
are nefarious things stop keeping it
from happening which i think is more
likely which is terrifying but how do
you how do you how do you solve for that
humans crave to be told what to do they
don't want to think for themselves you
see we're divergent we're the weirdos
who for some reason want to be
responsible for ourselves everyone else
just wants to be gently patted on the
back as they rest in the lap of you know
daddy biden i mean is it because that's
so terrifying to like
do you say that
like is it because people that are truly
free are dangerous
to society people who are truly free i
don't think they should be perceived as
dangerous our country was founded on the
idea of the individual having you know
uh individual rights superseding group
rights and it's reversing course now now
we're being told that we are idiots and
cursed at you know by
various youtubers or whatever because we
believe that individual rights supersede
group rights but obviously that's the
only way to ensure that there's equality
is to put the individual's rights first
you know what is it the whole thing
about like uh you know it's better that
that uh
100 guilty men go free than one innocent
man be imprisoned that's still true
that's still true you know what i love
about that franklin took that quote from
someone i remember blackstone blackstone
said it's better that two guilty people
i think it was the original quote was
two to one are you sure i think it was
the original it's like a greek quote
blackstone's formulation is that greek
no it's it's it's uh it's it's from
blackstone it's rooted in the story of
sodom and gomorrah well well the cool
thing is that that makes a lot of if it
is 10. i thought it was two but if it's
10 then he took a a a power of 10. he
took a magnitude great and then ben
franklin we should do that again it's
better than a thousand people go that's
why i agree with you that's why i oppose
cash bill i think cash bail is wrong
yeah rich people buying their way out of
jail so this is like indulgences this is
a big issue in new york because crime
went up because they ended cash bail and
this is a progressive issue aoc is very
much in favor of ending cash bail and i
completely agree with her the idea that
there's like some working-class dude who
gets arrested and accused of a crime and
then they say now you're going to sit in
jail for two months until your court
date you lose your job you lose your
apartment your family doesn't know where
you are or things of that nature it
happens to people because you didn't
have the thousand dollars to pay bail i
think is wrong what we need is a much
speedier court system i mean we have
such
there was a there was a young man who
actually died in prison because he
couldn't afford bail and it was over a
stolen backpack and he didn't do it and
i think he died in like rikers or
something like that you are innocent
until proven guilty the state should not
have the ability to to punish you in any
way unless it's a violent crime with
with with probable cause and they the
judge you know can actually what about
what about like recidivism do you have a
well in what capacity what do you mean
like if you're arrested multiple times
for violations for crimes uh is there
any point at which the state can hold
you like there was somebody recently i
think it was like killed people uh we
were gonna
cover a lot of this stuff i'm not
remembering the story but like someone
was arrested a bunch of times on gun
charges kept being released kept being
released kept being released and then
you know
see that's the problem about the tyranny
if somebody is arrested on a violent
crime
and they say
here's the person your honor here's our
probable cause as to why we believe you
know this person did this the judge will
then say like
due to the threat you are remanded to
custody right that makes sense if it's
someone who is like a non-violent
offender and this is what the the
progressives did
i'll tell you what they did wrong though
when they say this guy was arrested for
shoplifting and say what's your probable
cause well witnesses say he was
shoplifting that's not good enough but
we're gonna hold him no
cash bail is basically remand okay
that's not fair to someone who's working
class and can't afford it the problem is
you can't defend yourself
right you can't defend yourself you are
not secure in your person so what
happens is there was one guy who like he
got he was shoplifting like 30 times
right and they kept arresting him and
cutting him loose because the end of
cash bail and then he laughed when he's
getting arrested some i guess he said
something like i just keep doing it you
keep letting me go
it's like he was absolutely flouting the
rules he knew what he was doing right
see there's limits if someone does it
multiple times and your honor this is
the third time this person's been
arrested we have numerous witness
statements here are the statements the
judge can be like okay
you're not getting out this time dude i
think we really need a much speedier
trial system how do you do it when you
got 13 million people in one city you
know a quarter in every corner 13
million what's what's the greater
metropolitan area
the people who come into the city the
greater metropolitan area of new york
though i mean you don't have like all of
those people aren't subject to the same
courts no it's difficult the people who
come into and out of new york so you you
can live in jersey and drive into new
york for work and then get arrested and
then you're in the system end up in the
tombs whatever else yep end up in the
tombs what an awful name it is awful i
remember when a friend of mine was like
it was like i just spent the whole
weekend in the tombs that's
this is what happens police officers
know that rescue friday you can't get
out until monday exactly and that could
and then yeah and that could mean you
lose your job yep so he didn't have one
so it was okay there i i have had
friends who have been arrested uh
wrongly on fridays and then wait until
monday to get out it's insane it's crazy
it's nice and they lose their jobs it's
like you're two it should be seven two
two two no call no shows over two weeks
important to shut down
yes
and during kovid like a lot of the
courts were really backed up a lot of
things just didn't happen maybe we need
online courts
i don't know about that there's that
tendency that people won't won't fight
their own sit at their own neighbors so
maybe the problem with an online court
though is it removes the
it's like you were talking about earlier
with twitter right it's like it removes
the emotional aspect so when you when
you're a judge and you see a defendant
in a you know orange jumpsuit on a
closed-circuit prison camera are you
really going to
look at that guy and see his humanity
right no eye contact yeah there's
nothing there's nothing at all
do you think they'd be more guilty i
think they'd be more guilty yeah i mean
i think that we should have a speedy
court system
[Music]
where
an accused is brought before a judge
brought before a jury it shouldn't take
like months and months and months some
of these hearings take so long like just
to get to the hearing too many people
yeah one of the things that's uh it is
relatively easier for certain crimes
where it's like the cops themselves
witness it and they say we you know we
are witnesses but then they're still
agents of the state so it's very
difficult i don't like the idea that
credibility is given to the agents of
the state you know two people walk into
a court the cop says this guy you know
uh stole a banana and then the guy says
no i didn't the cop said yes he did the
court just believes the cop right you
know oh you arrested him and the cops
probably telling the truth and the jury
just believes the cop this is why there
are of course instances where the police
then plant the banana on the guy well
but yes but i think the most important
thing is that cops can make mistakes and
so i know a lot of people on the left
will be like cops plant drugs oh we've
seen it that body camera footage where
the guy puts the drugs in the it's under
a rock or something and then you don't
know what that is he accidentally turned
his camera on when he thought he was
turning it off
yeah but but more importantly
there's this really famous video on
youtube where a lawyer talks about why
you never talk to cops and he explains
that like
the cop could miss hear you
and then tell the jury he confessed and
the jury's gonna be like okay
yeah that's a rule that i grew up with
which is
don't ever talk to cops about anything
ever anything ever if you're ever
arrested
shut up anything ever because you never
shut up you never know if you're the
suspect and people are like oh but if
you're just a witness and that's what
happens you don't know that
that's the thing too like uh
you know in terms of calling police
officers for some reason if there's
something going on you have to be really
careful with that because cops show up
and they don't know who is who right and
so immediately they assume you know they
can make these assumptions that's a
difficult job
yeah and we're losing cops constantly
well you know how i feel about that
i'm not gonna
stand for the cops who are enforcing the
lockdowns and mandates and arresting
salon owners and uh and letting antifa
go so
there was a woman in minnesota she
opened her uh cafe
in defiance of the lockdowns and said
you know screw off and the sheriff's
went and they tracked her down and they
arrested was this the bar owner and she
like had a couple of kids and she was
trying to i don't know i don't know
about the greater details well there was
there might have been another one yeah i
don't i don't have any respect for
officers who are who are imposing and
enforcing lockdowns either look what's
going on in australia what happened to
australia oh man got colonized by the
there was there was a there was
apparently some story about a lady who
couldn't even cross over from like one
state to the next right like they've
actually locked their state or something
they've locked down everything it that
just seems insane to me they've been
telling me that it's different areas too
it's very different from area
right yeah but how do you stand for that
like how do you look at a police force
and say like yes you know i will stay in
my one man who was 86 years old died so
nine hundred thousand people have to get
locked in their homes it was one it was
literally one guy very old very old guy
who you know
probably died with covid in
i think this was in secaucus i could be
wrong a woman was she had a shop
and they locked everything down the
government ordered all businesses to be
closed so she went on facebook live and
started filming what she had in her
store saying if anybody wants to buy
anything just comment below so the cops
showed up knocked on the door and they
said ma'am you need to close your shop
and she said what are you talking about
we are closed and they're like no ma'am
you are trying to sell things online you
have to shut your shop down why can't
you sell things online what about
because ebay only weren't allowed to
sell things whatever was going on and
amazon was not about covid because the
cops came and told her to stop live
streaming on facebook yep that's
insanity where was that
new jersey i think that's where it was i
have to look it up yeah it was it was
somewhere it sounds like a new jersey
thing to have happen yeah it really does
and i'm sure it's not the only place
we saw we saw that they were letting
people out of jail
and then they were putting that like
that salon owner in texas in jail yeah
and she was very forthright she was like
i have people who work for me and i
don't want them to lose their homes i
told my mom i was thinking about uh
leaving new york i was like i don't
think i can make this work anymore mom
and she's like just moved to jersey i
was like nope mom that's the same place
yeah it's actually worse it's literally
the same place it's like stinky new york
it's like true yeah
i don't know man um what i i don't know
about what people in cities should do i
can't predict the future i do think
it'll just start getting worse i think
really
do you think i mean that's the
interesting thing it's like where can
you go i was talking to ben shapiro
about this because i was like you know
what happens when
people you know he was calling it like
the big sort you know like there's going
to be a big sort out
what happens like
will it eventually overtake the entire
country is there any authorization
that's going to be all right to live
probably like another internet just like
live like a free person and that's the
other thing too it's like is there going
to be an amazon for people who don't
want to support jeff bezos's crazy
empire i hope so did you see the polling
showing that um i think it's 37.2
percent of americans want their region
to separate from the us to form its own
regional union really which which
regions want out does no english so they
they they yes
so well but they're all about a third so
they'll be crazy there they broke up the
the country into five regions you've got
the pacific region you've got i think
the heartland region the mountain region
the southern and the northeast and
most are the plurality
uh in terms of
i should phrase this better on the west
coast pacific region democrats were the
largest group that wanted to secede from
the union in the south there was
republicans in the midwest it's
independent voters okay but the overall
average among all regions when i
actually went to the math i went through
the population of each state normalized
for population 37.2 percent of people in
this country are in favor of their area
breaking off from the us with the great
sort you are going to see those numbers
dramatically increase because the people
in the pacific region the 30 of
republicans who are there and want to
break off we'll move to texas and
bolster the republican number there and
increase it i think 60 of southern
republicans wanted to break away i think
that's like i want though like i want to
eat cake every day like they don't
really want they don't know what it is
they're saying they want if you want to
militarize you want you want like a war
like five tribal
north american
you know 21st century don't that's how
you split it up then we'll all go to
fight each other that'd be crazy that
would be pretty crazy
nuclear weapons
how many people understand the policies
they're voting for most of them seem not
to and so when people say i don't know
what i want the politicians read the
bills sometimes you're right they don't
what was it what was that the omnibus
was wheeled in on a wagon with five
thousand pages and nobody read it the
senate just voted for that but yeah it's
ridiculous then it just does so the
senate was asked recently wasn't it to
vote for the massive giant stupid
infrastructure bill before it was
written because the house like refused
to take it up unless the senate promised
that they would pass something that the
house drafted oh come on collusion
insanity and like basically nobody read
it because it doesn't exist there there
will be voting certain amount of
signatures to get something as a
referendum it'll appear on the ballot in
november and then people will see it and
as we already know x amount of people in
these regions want to secede so when
they're voting it'll be like would you
like your region to become its own
region they go oh yeah for sure and they
vote for it they don't care about the
other thing too is the way that the laws
are named they're named in very
obfuscatory ways so that you don't
really know what you're voting for right
yeah right like a like
like the yeah the patriot act
is the opposite of the patriot act or
like hr one they call you know they call
it like a for the people act
it's not at all it's actually like so
overreaching an authoritarian 16 year
old voting yes that's what it hasn't it
has like a provision that you have to
register people who are under 18 to vote
amazing that's in it thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time